bonjour christophe sira
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin dans la matinale d'ayrté
france alors on a vu les mesures que qui
ont été annoncées hier par le premier
ministre jean castex une réaction tout
d'abord on va parler évidemment de
difficulté après
oui bah ccc des demi-mesures c'est
surtout beaucoup d'effets d'annoncé
parce que là on est vraiment dans la
politique de distribuer des miettes et
c'est dramatique parce que le
gouvernement s'appuie sur ses effets
d'annoncé pour essayer de te calmer un
petit peu
ça va être une catastrophe parce que ça
va jamais suffire effectivement depuis
le mois d'août en vérité on a des
problèmes et depuis l'instauration du
passé militaire donc ça ne suffira
jamais ces choses là il faut absolument
arrêter toutes ces histoires ou alors
être rendez-vous vraiment où tout
arrêter et nous laisser travailler mais
on peut pas faire deux poids deux de
demi-mesure comme ça tout le temps parce
que c'est des annonces qui sont annoncés
à la va-vite effectivement vous l'avez
dit l'opa sanitaires devraient entrer en
vigueur peut-être la semaine prochaine
vous vous refusez d'ailleurs est ce que
vous faites partie de ces restaurateurs
qui refusent de l'appliquer
solutions d'identité pardon
oui voilà on sait plus de quoi on parle
ça veut dire n'importe quoi de toute
façon on sait que toutes ces mesures
depuis le début maintenant tout le monde
nous les lisons 10e même que ça n'a rien
de salutaire vous rendez compte comme
j'utilise nous
restaurant par exemple pour mener à bien
une politique
sanitaire mais qui n'est pas sanitaire
une politique vaccinale on est on est
les instruments de ça q que le
gouvernement l'admettent le
reconnaissent et soit à la hauteur de
ses ambitions à lui mais nous on n'a
rien à faire dans cette histoire c'est
pas salutaire donc on en train de payer
des pots cassés on en train de payer de
notre poche sur la fréquentation de nos
restaurants elle sur la la survie de nos
restaurants une politique dans laquelle
on n'a rien à voir est-ce que vous avez
constaté une baisse de fréquentation des
restaurants à cause de ce variant
omicron est ce que vous craignez une
baisse encore plus accentuée avec cette
obligation d'identité
l'obligation d'une anxiété honnêtement
je pense que c'est vraiment
sujet pour amuser la galerie bien sûr qu
on constate des baisses encore une fois
j'étais passé on y croit ou 6 cellules
et mesure où si c'est l'ambiance
générale c'est le télétravail en tout
cas les la baisse d'activité on la
constate ça croyez moi c'est sûr oui
parce qu'on a vu en en reportage le
télétravail aussi rend les choses
compliquées comment comment est-ce qu'on
peut être entré en télétravail quand on
travaille dans la restauration
dans la restauration peut pas faire de
la restauration ne peut pas donc nous on
ne peut qu'attendre les clients et les
regarder passer quand bernard mais vous
revoir mes comptes enfin
on enregistre des baisses de départ fois
80% de de fréquentation c'est c'est ça
c'est dramatique vraiment dramatique
qu'est ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui
un gouvernement concrètement pour vous
aider
on arrête tout ce cirque parce que c'est
pas ça l'était encore une fois et on
nous on nous sort de ce jeu là soit le
l'humanité malheureusement je suis navré
mais le gouvernement doit assumer ce qui
est de telle qu'ils la premier depuis le
début parce que la casse la casse va
être énorme si on continue comme ça
parce que les est encore une fois les
effets l'annoncent les aides entre
guillemets annoncé par exemple le
dispositif koushik ce qui a été annoncé
il ya deux semaines c'est juste
quasiment zéro c'est à dire que la la
bulle est l'immense majorité des
restaurateurs ne ne pourront pas y
prétendre selon le mode de calcul voilà
donc qui hier en nous on nous ressort un
autre truc de 20% la masse salariale il
faut 65 % du chiffre d'affaires mais
peut-être qu'à 30 ça marche pour autre
chose on n'y comprend rien ça va faire
des miettes et ça ne suffira jamais
en parallèle de ces mesures qui tombe
comme ça au compte-gouttes celle de
l'éducation nationale demain il ya une
grande mobilisation qui est annoncé à
nouveau vous vous sentez seul solidaires
de ce qui se passe dans le monde de
l'éducation nationale et de ce qui s'est
passé en tout cas avec jean michel
blanquer son voyage à alyssa
quelques jean michel blanquer a partagé
visage et c'est bien pour lui écoutez
franchement présentement comme ça
personnellement j'aurais préféré que son
protocole soit plus au point qu'il l'ait
fait même d'encore plus loin
qu'on soit solidaires sur le fait que
tout le monde en a marre oui
ensuite je pense vraiment qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on arrête tout ça il faudra
mentionner les données scientifiques qui
sont à la disposition de tous y compris
de deux mois et qui les comprend soit vu
par les dirigeants aussi et qu'ils ont
tué les blés les bonnes conséquences on
considère ça comme un aîné de maladies
comme d'autres hivernale et puis qu'on
arrête ce cinéma
encore une fois qui m'a plombé et
l'économie et le tout le climat social
on le voit bien on voit quand même que
la france elle est sans dessus dessous
quand même c'est tout ou rien qui marche
alors les scientifiques qu'il dit ce
qu'il y aura une embellie non on le voit
aussi il y à il ya plus de quatre cent
soixante mille nouveaux cas de
contamination qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
je sais pas c'est des gens bien portants
apparemment c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle c'est des gens qui sont
positifs qui sont pas malades est plus
par exemple à cause de ce pass vaccinale
les non vaccinés qui ne pourront plus
venir dans votre restaurant pour vous
c'était une erreur
l'erreur c'est de trier les gens puisque
de toute façon tout le monde se comptent
à lille on le sait donc l'erreur c'est
d'organiser un tri sélectif qui
discrimine équipe qui plombe l'ambiance
dans tout le pays voilà ça c'est
l'erreur merci beaucoup on a entendu
votre appel merci christophe sira
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france